[音楽]
あればのえっとあの写真と感じだったんですけど恋のけどあの映画監督やっていますよ
公と申します
えーっとですね僕は母のことがすごく大好きです
昔からですね肌が大事にしてた言葉です
おかげということもずっと僕小さい頃から
ん
言われておりました
何勧めしてもあの人のおかげでどこかでおかげという気持ちば
聖なるため野党
今日のこの場はですねほんとにあの沢山の方の
おかげでネジのホイ食べていると思っております
まずはの感謝を述べたいと思いますありがとうございます
そしてあの今日ですね僕の妻もですね
農協ちょっとお邪魔しております途中ですね
ちょっと持ちほどあのちょっとあのせっかくなので
ただしいただいてい
参加してもらおうかと思っていますはい一番はい
あの北長崎県佐世保市で生まれましてね
今東京で10年ほど映像の制作の仕事をしております
職業はまあ映画監督ということで酔わせていただいたんですけども
僕の仕事はですねエンターテインメント
だと思っています
エンターテイメントって何だろう
で自分の中でですね
心刺激だと思っています
茂木どういう刺激を
与えられるのか
心をどう動かすのか
その中で
まあフォアされたりとか
喜びたいとまぁ喜怒哀楽があると思うんですけども
僕はあの
このですね感動をする
感動していただく
これを自分は映画の製作において選んでおります
家族家族愛というものですね
底面を選んでおります
今長編2作目はですねええ
長崎で撮らせていただいたんですけども一昨年も2作目も
家族愛というものをテーマに
映画を撮らせていただきました
なぜ僕がの家族愛に
テーマを置いたのかという話を強調つ入ってるかと
持っています
僕はですね
この仕事について
8年くらいですね26歳になって
ディレクターになりました
その作るディレクターの仕事についてです
今までミュージックビデオだったり
テレビにお仕事だったとか
コマーシャル例えば塾や強いられたんですけれども
基本的には
受け仕事です
クライアントの発注があって
こういう映像を作ってほしいというものに対して僕らは少し
どうだったら応えられるか
っていうものに対して今まで考えてきました
いろんなあの映像の仕事をした後にですね
僕はやっぱり物語が a tight
26の時に思いまして
映画を撮ろうと決めました
ただですね
映画を撮ろうと思っても僕取ったことはありませんし
一番近かったのはん
今まで受け仕事だったんですけれども
今度はね能動的に
考えないといけなかったんですね
なんでこの映画を撮りたいのか
あなたこれをなんで世の中に出したいとか
これを自分で言えることができないと
お金は出してくれる人も
うんと言ってくれないと
ここでですねも考えたんですね自分は一体
何を伝えられて
何をやらない
やることができるんだろうこれ始めて考えました
僕が
その時にたまたまですね
ショートショートフィルムフェスティバルという
東京で行われていますもう20年ぐらいやってみますね
短編映画祭に
作品を
出店していないかと
というお話をいただきました
僕はちょうどいい機会なのでじゃあ自分は
何を取るんだろういうことで考えてです
大体なんでもいいと言われたんですねなんでもいい
3じっくりでもいいですしドキュメンタリーでもいいですしなんでもいい
僕が取ったのがですね
その頃地元に母だけいたんですけども
母のドキュメンタリーを撮りました
5分くらいのドキュメンタリーだったんですから
そこでですね僕は自分が大事にしてる物っていうのは家族で母と
ねえ
地元にある長崎北これをすごく大事にしているんだなぁ
いうことに気づきました
なので家族の愛をテーマ
がを取っていこうと
決めたんですね1本目の徴兵階ラリーという作品だったんですけれども
これは家族の愛をテーマに去年の11月に公開できました
これは金沢で撮影させていただいたんですけれども
いろんなのクレープさんの関係もあってですね
必ず探しています
楢崎でカナダ方ですよ
で今回に削減を
1作目はあのを取れたのでじゃあ次も家族愛の映画を
もともと僕は大事思っている家族愛家族と地元というものをこれをやっぱり
スポットのか長崎で撮りたいと思っ
a
おととしからですね企画を準備してい
長崎を盛り上げるべく
進めてきました
こんなことですね
今年は4月に撮影撮り終えまして
今編集し行きです
ちょうど音楽を作っているところですけど
そこでですね僕が8
[音楽]
すごく長崎で撮影をさせて頂いている間に
起きたですいな出来事が3つありまして
それはちょっとへ
妻とですね漫談しながら足場
ご紹介好きなところ
とった
親なん
8ですね
あつまろ遠藤空域で進んだいません
[拍手]
まとして主人の横に行きませんはいありがとうございます
8ですねまず一つ目なんですけどもあの撮影の前にですね
ロケハン t ものをするんですね
ロケーションハンティングの撮影場所を決めるため
それで僕はの結構スタッフと一緒に
長崎市内ぐるぐる回ってですねー
お昼ご飯は家を食べなくて
通り市内のところで止まってくるのを止めでちょっと探してたんですね
ただしいったんはですね
お母様がですねそこの地元お母さんの声をかけてくださったんですね
ましたよね
ああ
偽物ですねねぇー
こっちの練習しましたので撮っ
tee
ha
パペペン色歯医者探してましてっ
顔しちゃダメさすいませんがちょっとご飯をちょっと探してまして入れるとこちょっと
とかないかなーと思っていま
nao
the やったねーあそこに
中間盛んで中華ですかうーんポッド下あたりになるんですよ
ああ
なチャン政府めっ本当ですか
ありがとうございます
[拍手]
at レーサー no
僕今まで東京でマージ18年ぐらいも仕事してるんですけども一回もないです
自分から聞きに行ったことがあるんですけども
何か困ってるとって聴いてくださるっていう
こんなこんな優しい
た人がの
朝食にいらっしゃるんだなと思ったエピソードとかこれ一つですね
二つめ来ますね
これはですねあのこれは4月撮影中に
夜の民家の撮影をしてました
夜の民家夜の撮影ですのでちょっと外から照明を当てて撮影をしてたんですねそしたら
よくあるんですけどもあの
かなりの原因もですねちょっとライトがちょっと向いて行ったりとかしたい
ちょっとまぶしくなっている
そしたら隣の
あたらですね巣から出てこられたんですね
暴れるかなと思ったんですけど
鋭いん
魂をとあ
御畳瀬なんか尼子氏か確かめください
稲佐山こと中山アウトですかもうちょっと映画の撮影してまして
まああと2時間ぐらいでおりますので
ありませんそれやったら描くしても良かったの
あどっ長とぞあのもうあのベースは後ろでどうぞあ見ています
と言ってですねありがとう
2015分か20分ほど見ていただけて
見ていただきましたその後です
夜明けましたありがとうございます
お礼に家で事を作る気を持ってるかね
いいんですか
ありがとうございます
コラム脚部スタッフも見えたんですけど
おしっこぐらいですねあの高級で防犯をいただきまして
いやもう
普通だったら怒られてるんですね僕の経験上今まで約なんで眩しいと
舐めろとスゴ我はみたいなことだったんですけどそんなことなく
でここまで頂けた
ここに思いやりのある叩かれるんだなぁそう
エピソードです
最後ですね
はいん
これはですね撮影の
合間にですねぜひ僕がの長編1本目の映画を地元長崎でぜひ流したいと思ってですね
直接僕が長崎の映画館に直談判しまして電話して
あの直接を前に新切手です
お願いした時のエピソード
館長さんん
どうですかね僕の映画一本目をジョイしていただけないでしょうかね
はねぇ断った
そうですよね洋菓子か皆さんに皆様がの胞子ターン
医院名
声だ言ってくれだけねー
上映戦は日にはいたんだねぇいいんですか
はいありがとうございません
それでこれで醤油していただけたんです
こんなことがあるんだって本当に思いました
やっぱり東京ではどちらがで予定したのか
2時だったりでやっぱこうそれを提出する
長崎にはこんな沢山の
アイガー子供気づいたんですね
も公開タイプ地元なんでしょうとの好きなんだと
僕は頃
愛があるということに気づきました
この振っこの想いある人を思いやり優しタラッタりこない家族ある面白そうなんです
けどもこれが僕は日本人がこれから日本人なりじゃなくても大事にしていくべき
アイデンティティだなぁとすごく感じました
これをですね僕はへ
長崎から
失敗する長崎からです世界そして子どもたちですね
その愛を伝えるべく
映像を作り続けていけたらなと
最後にあるの愛するつまりありがとう
終わりたいと思います今日はありがとうございました
hair さん
ました俺数
ああああああ